es el golfo de Guayaquil uno de los
principales puntos de exportación de
cocaína del mundo Este es un operativo
de la marina ecuatoriana una inspección
rutinaria
desde 2021 la policía decomisado cerca
de 500 toneladas de drogas en registros
como este y en algún tiene algo
algún objeto contundente contrapuntes
Ecuador al estar entre Perú y Colombia
los mayores productores de cocaína se ha
convertido en un lugar clave para el
narcotráfico los homicidios
prácticamente se duplicaron entre 2021 y
2022 este golfo es complicado de
contener porque les da la facilidad de
la salida al mar para realizar
sus actividades ilícitas es fácilmente
para ellos llegar a
a estas vías a estos accesos de los
brazos del mar del Golfo pero los grupos
criminales no solo atemorizan a las
fuerzas de seguridad también a Los
Pescadores que viven en la zona les
cobran alrededor de 30 dólares a la
semana para trabajar extorsiones y robos
la familia de Hilda Vera hace Guardia
nocturna hace poco les quitaron un motor
todo da miedo Oiga salir a pescar como
salir a cangrejal para todo da miedo
la solución del gobierno ha sido
decretar varios estados de excepción e
incluso el porte de armas de defensa
personal Aunque bajo requisitos
estrictos sin embargo el miedo no cesa